en el vídeo anterior vimos un repaso de
la adaptación potasio árbol y en este
vídeo me gustaría que veamos un ejemplo
concreto en el que involucraremos un
poco de álgebra y decaimiento
exponencial quiero mostrarles cómo
pueden calcular la edad de una roca
volcánica aplicando un poco de
matemáticas entonces sabemos que
cualquier cosa que experimenta un
decaimiento radioactivo experimenta un
decaimiento exponencial y existe una
forma generalizada de describirlo pero
eso lo veremos más a fondo en otros
vídeos de caná cádiz por ahora sabemos
que una cierta cantidad de algo está en
función del tiempo y podemos decir que n
es la cantidad de muestra radioactiva
que vamos a analizar y esto es igual a
la cantidad inicial que había de eso
antes de la descomposición vamos a
llamarla n subíndice 0
y esto por el ala menos acá de donde
está constante corresponde
particularmente a la vida media de lo
que sea que tengamos y para resolver
esto veamos un ejemplo con potasio 40
sabemos que después de cada 1.25 mil
millones de años nos queda la mitad de
la cantidad que teníamos inicialmente
entonces vamos a escribirlo así
empezamos con n 0 que puede ser un gramo
un kilogramo 5 gramos etcétera lo que
sea que era la cantidad original por el
nada menos que por 1.25 mil millones de
años que lo podemos escribir como 1.25
por 10 a la 9
esa es la vida media del potasio 40 1.25
mil millones de años después de ese
largo periodo de tiempo la mitad de la
muestra se ha descompuesto entonces
escribimos un medio de n 0 es decir de
lo que había inicialmente después de
1.25 mil millones de años y después de
1.25 mil millones de años sólo nos queda
la mitad ok y si ahora dividimos ambos
lados entre n 0 para despejar que
simplemente aplicamos logaritmo natural
en ambos lados y nos queda logaritmo
natural de un medio porque ya cancelamos
n 0 y esto es igual a logaritmo natural
de todo esto el logaritmo natural nos
indica a qué potencia se eleva y para
obtener el ala menos k por 1.25 mil
millones así que el logaritmo natural de
esto es decir la potencia a la que
elevamos es para
tener el ala menos k por 1.25 mil
millones es simplemente menos k por 1.25
por 10 a la 9 ok y después para despejar
k podemos dividir ambos lados de la
ecuación por menos 1.25 mil millones y
así nos queda que acá voy a escribirlo
del lado derecho acá es igual a
logaritmo natural de un medio entre
menos 1.25 por 10 a la 9 y observen que
el signo negativo puede estar
multiplicando únicamente al numerador oa
toda la fracción entonces podemos
escribir esto como 1.25 por 10 a la 9
estos son 1.25 mil millones y el menos
logaritmo natural de un medio bueno
miren podemos escribirlo de esta forma
si tenemos a por el logaritmo natural de
p por las propiedades de los logaritmos
sabemos
que esto es igual a logaritmo natural de
b elevado a la potencia a entonces el
menos logaritmo natural de un medio es
igual a logaritmo natural de un medio a
la menos 1 así que esto es igual a bueno
como cualquier cosa elevada a una
potencia negativa es igual a su
multiplicación inversa esto es igual a
logaritmo natural de 2 entonces el menos
logaritmo natural de un medio es
simplemente el logaritmo natural de 2
así es como podemos despejar acá k es
igual a logaritmo natural de 2 entre la
vida media de la sustancia y esto lo
podemos generalizar para cualquier otra
sustancia radioactiva ok y ahora que ya
conocemos acá pensemos en una situación
en la que en alguna muestra encontramos
vamos a suponer que en una muestra
encontramos un miligramo de potasio
supongamos que encontramos un miligramo
de potasio 40 y que de argón 40
encontramos 0.01 miligramos entonces
cómo podemos usar esta información junto
con lo que acabamos de calcular a partir
de la vida media para saber qué tan
antigua es esta muestra cómo podemos
saber eso bueno sabemos que n
la cantidad restante es igual a esto
entonces sabemos que nos queda un
miligramo un miligramo y esto es igual a
una cierta cantidad inicial para la que
usamos esta información por el ala menos
acá por t y ya conocemos acá porque acá
es igual a todo esto pero ahora
necesitamos conocer la cantidad inicial
para poder calcular t y saber qué tan
antigua es la muestra entonces vamos a
ver para conocer la cantidad inicial
recuerden que el argón 40
a partir de potasio 40 porque recuerden
que cuando el potasio se descompone el
11% se descompone en argón 40 y el 89
por ciento restante se descompone en
calcio 40 eso lo vimos en el vídeo
anterior entonces lo que sea que
tengamos de argón 40 corresponde al 11%
de la descomposición o mejor dicho del
decaimiento radioactivo del potasio 40
así que si queremos pensar en el número
total de potasio es 40 que se
desintegraron desde que esto se quedó
atrapado en la roca porque recuerden que
todo el argón 40 que había en el momento
en que había lava todo ese argón se
liberó antes de que la lava se
solidificará y bueno para saber de
cuánto potasio 40 proviene todo esto
simplemente dividimos entre 11 por
ciento entonces podemos decir que acá
inicial el potasio 40 inicial es igual a
la cantidad de potasio 40 que tenemos
ahora qué
un miligramo más la cantidad de potasio
40 que necesitamos para obtener esta
cantidad de argón 40 entonces si tenemos
esta cantidad de argón 40 0.01
miligramos y esa cantidad corresponde
únicamente al 11% de la cantidad
original que había de potasio 40 y el
resto se convirtió en calcio 40 entonces
vamos a dividir esto entre 11 por ciento
es decir 0.11 y bueno este no es el
número exacto pero nos da una idea
general entonces inicialmente que sería
n 0 esto es igual a vamos a ver un
miligramo es igual a un miligramo que es
lo que encontramos más 0.01 miligramos
entre 0.11 y todo esto por el ala menos
acá por t
y aquí podemos ver que si despejamos t
suponiendo que conocemos que en realidad
la cantidad no importa mucho porque lo
que más importa es la relación entonces
para despejarte primero vamos a dividir
ambos lados de la ecuación entre todo
esto y así nos queda que del lado
izquierdo tenemos un miligramo entre
todo esto entonces tenemos uno más
mejor de una vez vamos a suponer que las
unidades son miligramos
entonces mejor simplemente escribimos 1
entre 1 + 0.01 / 0.11 y eso es igual
a la menos k porte y si queremos
despejar t necesitamos aplicar el
logaritmo natural en ambos lados
entonces nos queda logaritmo natural de
1 entre 1 + 0.01 entre 0.11 y eso es
igual a menos que corte y finalmente
vamos a dividir ambos lados de la
ecuación entre menos que lo escribiré
por acá es un poco largo el proceso
matemático pero así es como llegamos a
la respuesta entonces tenemos que t es
igual a logaritmo natural de uno entre
uno más
0.01 / 0.11 y todo eso entre menos que
pero que era menos que bueno menos que
es simplemente lo negativo de esto
entonces entre menos el logaritmo
natural de 2 / 1.25 por 10 a la 9 ok
ahora si podemos usar nuestra
calculadora para saber cuál es el tiempo
que será en años porque fue como
calculamos esta constante vamos a ver
primero resolveré esta parte tenemos uno
entre 1 + 0.01 entre 0.11 y eso es igual
a este número y si a eso le aplicamos el
logaritmo natural nos queda menos 0
puntos 0 87
ese es el numerador y eso lo vamos a
dividir entre abrimos paréntesis
- el logaritmo natural de 2 / 1.25 por
10 a la 9 entonces entre 1.25 por 10 a
la 9 ok
cerramos los dos paréntesis y finalmente
obtenemos que nuestra t en años es igual
a vamos a ver todo eso es igual a 156.9
millones de años entonces si lo
redondeamos nuestra muestra es de
aproximadamente 157 millones de años
millones de años de antigüedad
ok y bueno el desarrollo matemático fue
un poco largo pero es algo que verán en
alguna clase de cálculo o de álgebra de
nivel intermedio cuando estudian
crecimiento exponencial y decaimiento y
bueno la finalidad de hacer todo esto no
es que se expanden con toda esta
explicación y vayan a pensar que está
difícil en realidad estas son
matemáticas que les enseñan en la
preparatoria y con eso ustedes pueden
saber que si tienen una muestra que
tiene esta relación de algún 40 con
respecto al potasio 40 podrán saber que
esta es una roca volcánica de 157
millones de años de antigüedad